-I love you guys.
Thank you very, very much.
Enjoy yourself.
Guys, today, Americans went
to the polls for Election Day.
-Whoo.
-Yeah. This morning,
on Instagram,
Taylor Swift encouraged
her 275 million
followers to vote.
And long story short,
she's now the governor
of Kentucky and Mississippi.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Yeah. Today is what's known
as an off-year election.
Basically, if the midterms
and presidential elections
are Target,
today was Marshalls.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, in Ohio, one of
the biggest issues they voted on
was whether or not
to legalize marijuana.
[ Scattered cheers ]
You know if it's legal in Ohio
if they changed
their name to O-we-hi-yo.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Today --
Today, I noticed tons of people
were walking around
with their "I voted" stickers,
and this year, there's actually
a bunch of new voting stickers
to choose from.
For instance, there's...
[ Laughter ]
That's good.
Then there's...
[ Laughter ]
Next is...
Next, there's...
[ Laughter ]
-That's a big --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Big Issue.
Next is...
[ Laughter ]
Next, there's...
And, finally...
There you go.
Oh, there you go.
Keep an eye out for those.
[ Applause ]
Well, speaking of elections,
tomorrow night in Miami,
NBC is airing the third
Republican presidential debate.
And once again, former president
Trump is not participating.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
So, tomorrow at 9:00 p.m.,
CBS has "The Amazing Race,"
and NBC has the opposite.
[ Laughter ]
The debate is at Miami-Dade
County Center
for the Performing Arts.
Yep, for the Performing Arts.
Because pretending
you have a shot
when you're polling at 1%,
well, that's acting.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Switching gears,
this is exciting.
Today, Barbra Streisand
released her new memoir,
and it's nearly
1,000 pages long.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Yikes.
And the book has already been
selected as the one Ron DeSantis
will stand on
during tomorrow's debate.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
1,000 pages.
If you order it online,
you have to unbox it
like it's one of those
Casper mattresses.
Like, "Whoa!
Wow!
How did that fit in that?"
[ Laughter ]
That's right. Barbra Streisand's
memoir is almost 1,000 pages.
And get this -- the audiobook
is 48 hours long.
-Whoa.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-What? Of course.
It's not easy to read that much,
which is why Streisand actually
had a few celebrities
help her read some passages.
-Really?
-That's correct.
For example,
Michael Caine read this passage.
Probably both.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, like, Mick Jagger
read this passage.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
Wow.
-Yeah, no, this is --
-Who else did it?
-Stanley Tucci.
-Really?
-Stanley Tucci, from his --
his travel show.
He's very popular.
-Yeah, Italy.
-Obviously, yeah.
But he read this passage.
-Mmm. Mm.
Mm-mm-mmm! Delicious."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
He just said, "Mmm."
Wow.
-Yeah.
Dave Matthews.
-Dave Matthews
from Dave Matthews Band.
-Uh-huh. He read this passage.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
Wow!
And was there anyone else?
-Finally, there was
one more person.
-Oh, really?
One more?
Could you give me a beat,
like, a bo, bo-co, ki?
♪♪
Yeah. Good.
Bruce Springsteen
read this passage.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
There you go. That's --
Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's a fascinating...
-Wow.
-...fascinating listen.
Some business news.
I saw that Nike is suing
New Balance and Skechers
for allegedly stealing
their shoe-making technology.
-Ooh.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
New Balance said
the allegations are untrue,
while Skechers said,
"Wow. Nike knows who we are?"
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, my...
Hi."
[ Giggles ]
"Wow."
Hey, guys.
I read that Kahlua
and Absolut Vodka teamed up
to create a $100 fragrance
that smells
like an espresso martini.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, it's already been called
the number-one scent
to not wear on a job interview.
[ Laughter ]
If you don't have 100 bucks for
the espresso martini cologne,
just wait a few weeks and have
a mall Santa breathe on you.
[ Laughter ]
"What do you --
What do you want
for Christmas this year?"
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news.
Apple TV+ just announced
that they're making
a new original "Peanuts" movie
set in New York City.
-Ooh.
-[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-That's good.
That makes sense,
because when
the subway conductors talk,
they pretty much
sound like this.
[ "Peanuts" teacher warbling ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
"This stop?
He say it's stopping?"
Yeah, "Peanuts" is back,
but let's be honest --
right now, Bluey
is looking at Snoopy like,
"You're the Skechers
to my Nike."
[ Laughter ]
Guys, it is Tuesday.
It is time for WePost.
Let's play this game.
-♪ WePost ♪
♪♪
♪ WePost ♪
-Now this is "WePost."
This is where we,
as a group, decide something
that we should
all post on socials.
Actually, that I'm gonna post
on socials.
Okay, yeah. But I'm gonna show
you five different posts,
and we are all
going to vote on
whether you like
each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats?
All right, good. You can vote
for all of them, if you like.
You can vote for none of them,
if you like.
Whatever you want. We're going
to see the results live.
Higgins, Robert Glasper,
you guys have your clickers?
Everyone's got
their stuff ready to go?
All right. And I will say,
I will remind everyone,
not necessarily do they get
funnier as they go on.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-So if you feel like
it remotely has a shot,
yeah, why not?
Yeah, it's for fun, yeah.
-Some of these
are just sentences, right?
-Yes. I'm gonna post
whichever one
gets the most likes
from all of us
because it's not a me post.
It's a we post.
-Oh.
[ Cheering ]
All right.
You guys ready?
-Yeah!
-First post is...
[ Laughter ]
-"They were talking about you."
-"Why --
Why are they talking about me?
Why --
I'm trending."
[ Both laugh ]
All right, cast your votes.
Thumbs up or thumbs down.
All right. The votes are in.
Let's see the results
for this first one here.
Not bad. Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not good.
Not good, either, but not bad.
Yeah. No.
All right.
This next one says...
-Oh.
Wow.
[ Laughter ]
That did not sound
like they liked that one.
-I mean, I thought I liked it,
but, no.
-No, apparently not.
-Now I'm gonna vote no
on this one.
-Sounds like they made
that whole joke
out of the first bite.
-No. Yeah. All right. Good.
Yeah. All right, let's see.
I don't even know if I want
to see the results on this one.
-Do you want to see this one?
-I don't really want to see it,
but let's do it.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my...
[ Audience exclaims ]
At least you know
the clickers work.
[ Laughter ]
Wow!
-38.
-Wow.
Let me know how you really feel.
Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
I think that first bite
is delicious.
-Sure.
So is the rest of the pizza.
-Yeah, that's true.
[ Laughter ]
It is true.
It doesn't quite make sense.
All right.
This next one says...
[ Laughter ]
-Come on, that's a good one.
Come on.
♪♪
Mom...
-I don't know.
It can't get much worse
than the pizza one.
All right, let's see
the results here.
Oh, yeah, that's very nice.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
People being ni--
People were being nice.
-Yeah.
-People were being very nice.
-Humorous.
-That's how great this city is.
They come together
when they see --
When they see
that you're hurting,
they're right there for you.
They go, "Jimmy, come here."
-Then they kick you
while you're down.
-"It's not that bad.
That pizza one was bad,
but, come on,
we're there for you."
I appreciate that, guys.
This next one here says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
I don't know.
I'm doing it to be nice.
I don't know if this is --
Let's see the results here.
Yeah, yeah, I agree.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Tartar sauce walked...
-No, I could tell immediately,
they were like,
"No, we were nice,
and now we're being real."
[ Laughter ]
I appreciate it.
I totally agree with you.
This last one, I feel like
this one might do it.
-This one's a good one.
-Well, I don't know about that,
but I think this one might
be the one that wins.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
What was the other one
that we have so far in the lead?
-Doc Marten.
-Doc Marten, emo boots.
That's funny. Yeah.
-Medical degree.
-This one mi--
This is the last one.
If you like it, let me know.
If you don't...
Well, you know...
You already have
let me know. Okay.
Last one is...
[ Laughter ]
I feel you.
-Come on.
I'm kind of feeling.
-No, I'm feeling good
about this one.
I think this one
might be a winner.
I feel good.
-It's going to be high.
-Let's see the results
right here.
-Whoa!
-Oh, yeah!
We have a winner right there!
Come on, now!
[ Ding! ]
Futon! I'm gonna post this
during the break.
If you happen
to see it online,
give that WePost a repost.